[Music]
hello how are you greeting héctor
mejía with his briefing today is
wednesday may 5 as of this morning the
metropolitan police are still
investigating a fatal shooting
involving one of their officers at
night near charlestown and the
officers are here  They received several reports
about a man shooting from his
apartment when they arrived at the scene. They
said that this subject fired once
and ran to take refuge in his home
while the officers waited for
more units. They indicated that the suspect
came out with a weapon and that's when he
broke out.  the shooting will reveal more
information along with the video from the
body cameras after the
72 hour period has expired meanwhile the
burial resorts organizes
job fairs today and tomorrow these will be from
nine in the morning to four in the afternoon
inside the convention center of the
hotel and casino mandalay bay looking to
hire for various areas
you can find a complete list of
jobs at  our kirchner page
as diagonal in spanish celebrate may 5
getting your
coronavirus vaccine clark county is hosting
a party tonight inside
the east las vegas community center
starting at half past five all you
have to do  is to attend there will be food
folk music games and immunizations
available we have a full list
of events for today May 5th on our
page and social media now we kick off
with the weather forecast we will have
plenty only today with
warmer temperatures in the mid 90s for
the  afternoon and then tomorrow winds
from the southwest with gusts of
25 miles per hour stronger winds
on Friday at more than 30 miles per hour
have a nice day I am héctor mejía and
this was your brief news
neon Spanish
[Music]